[Music]
officials in columbus ohio are calling
for patience in due process
following the police involved shooting
death of a teenage girl
it's a complicated case the girl makia
bryant was swinging a knife at another
woman
when police arrived at the scene and the
ohio bureau of investigations
has begun a probe but lebron james has
no time for due process
he wants that cops hide now james
tweeted out a picture of the officer to
his nearly 50 million followers with a
simple and direct message
you're next senator ted cruz of texas is
here now to react
uh senator cruz what is your reaction to
this tweet from lebron james
well you know unfortunately this is a
pattern where the left
consistently goes after attacks and
demonizes police officers and they do so
often before the facts are known often
before there's any evidence of what
happened
but their immediate reaction whenever
there's an incident is the police
officers in the wrong
the police officer is is
the villain in in this instance your
next
could could certainly be interpreted by
some even for as a call for violence and
i think it was a
grossly irresponsible message for lebron
james to send out and
we've now seen the body cam footage from
what occurred and and by any measure it
was a volatile situation the the woman
who was killed
was wielding a knife was violent
appeared to be threatening the lives of
others
and it may well be on an investigation
that this police officer
saved the life of a potential victim of
a knife attack
and and and we should jump to
conclusions there needs to be an
investigation anytime there is a
shooting that takes someone's life it
should be investigated the facts
should be determined but the left
doesn't care about the facts they care
about demonizing and attacking law
enforcement
and i think it's wrong you know senator
i know that you're someone who cares a
great deal
about the degree to which we've seen
these
capitalist entities american companies
engage in politics in recent months in a
way that they
really haven't before taking sides on
culture war issues in an unprecedented
way obviously
the nba was one of these entities in the
past but
one of the things that i'm concerned
about is
what is to be done what can be done
to push back and to brush back these
american corporations
that seem to really have as their
priority list
these woke issues and and these and
these anti
frank frankly anti-law enforcement
anti-law and order
approaches when it comes to their
engagement with politics
well the past month in particular has
been really ominous in that that we've
seen the rise of the woke
corporations we've seen giant companies
readily enlisting to be the enforcers
of democrats and the extreme left
remaining in power
and and look i think many ceos
particularly ceos at big companies
they're risk-averse they're
they're scared and and the left has
invested for over a decade they've
invested in infrastructure where they
have lists
of left-wing employees at every big
company they have lists
of left-wing shareholders at every big
company and they've learned that these
ceos act to act like
like like scared little children that if
they get a few of their lefty employees
or a few of their lefty shareholders
pounding them
that that they just make the decision to
give in and right now
i i think even for the most apolitical
of of ceos
as they look at the cost-benefit
analysis the costs
and the benefits of giving in to the
woke left-wing mob
exceed what they perceive to be the cost
but but but a
reckoning is coming i believe we saw
delta airlines
do this and give in in atlanta in a way
that was shameful we've seen coca-cola
do it
we saw i think most disturbingly major
league baseball yank
the all-star game out of atlanta and
move it to denver and i gotta say
ben it really does illustrate how absurd
and
unconnected the substance these moves
are atlanta
is 51 percent african they moved it to
denver a city that is
nine percent african-american because
they're such wake
woke social justice warriors that
they're gonna take a hundred million
dollars out of the pockets
of the african-american small businesses
and workers in atlanta it makes no sense
it's dangerous and and i do think there
is a strong
backlash that is building because the
american people when you go to a
baseball game you're not interested in
their lecturing you on left-wing
politics you'd like to see people
play a game of baseball well the thing
that i'm concerned about senator is that
we have these
these handful of institutions that still
unite us
in american life and we see them being
torn apart
by this woke leftism which is taking
over
all of these different entities that had
been unifying elements of american life
that we could all go to a baseball game
together
and cheer alongside each other
regardless of race of religion etc
to me this is something that has to be
solved from the bottom up from the
communities
and we need these and we need these
corporations to
get back to being you know in the
business of being american companies
what can you
do as a politician to try to force them
into that lane as opposed to
the direction that they're going that
seems fundamentally anti-american
well you could call them out you can
shine a light on them and you can also
end any special subsidies or benefits
they get
when major league baseball moved the
all-star game out of atlanta playing
naked politics i joined with several
other senators in introducing
legislation to revoke
the special exemption from the antitrust
laws that major league baseball gets
that no other sports league
gets that's an example where you don't
get to come and get subsidies from the
government
while you're playing politics beyond
that shining a light
is really important you know last year
the nba decided they were going to get
very political they put black lives
matter on the courts
and and their profits plummeted the
phrase go woke
go broke i think that is a potent
deterrent and and i think there's going
to be a lot more discussion
about how not to patronize companies
that decide half of america they don't
care about us they don't want our
support
there need to be consequences for that
republicans buy sneakers too of course
thank you so much senator cruz for
joining me tonight thank you
coming up the new cold war against china
heating up
how beijing is beating us on the
cultural battlefield
newt gingrich is standing by on this one
straight ahead